So as most of you know, I am not with Joe
Biden on healthcare.
Joe Biden is starting the negotiation from
a very centrist point, which is let's tweak
Obamacare and add a public option.
We'd be lucky to get to that if you start
the conversation at the most progressive point,
if that's where Joe starts, we won't even
get that.
And I'm not with them whatsoever.
I'm not with Joe Biden on cannabis legalization.
He's against it.
I'm for it.
Joe Biden recently said cannabis is a gateway
drug that's been widely debunked beyond it
being a gateway to violence when it's illegal,
because people have to get into situations
that are less than savory in order to get
their cannabis.
But beyond that, it's not a gateway drug.
I am well to Joe Biden's left.
I'm a Warren Bernie guy, but I must tell you
I reviewed Joe Biden's tax plan and it's like
sort of okay in a very mild way, I guess I'm
saying it's not terrible given lots of Joe
Biden's other positions.
Now of course there is no wealth tax and Biden's
plan, he told a group of wealthy donors behind
closed doors that their wealth is basically
safe.
If he becomes president, he won't do anything
to radically change or challenge their privileged
position in society.
That's not a surprise, but given how off Joe
Biden has been in so, so many other areas,
his tax plan is better than I would have expected.
So let's take a look at it and discuss it.
Let's go through some of our bigger deals
than others.
First of all, taxing capital gains and dividends
as income is huge right now.
Capital gains taxes max out at 20% so if you're
a wealthy person who would pay the top rate
on earned income money you make via dividends
and capital gains is only taxed at 20% if
you tax capital gains and dividends has ordinary
income, you will collect significantly more
money from the very rich who are mostly earning
money from dividends and capital gains own
businesses.
They own stocks they owned, for example, rather
than labor.
This is a big deal.
Of course, people will find ways to try to
get around it, but this is a really big deal.
A Joe Biden would raise the corporate tax
rate to 28% this is fine.
Trump lowered it from 35 to 21 but what's
important to remember is that huge corporations
often don't play it, pay anything close to
what the corporate tax rate is anyway because
of loopholes.
Many corporations pay zero or even get tax
credits.
So I agree that we should bring the corporate
tax rate back up.
This is not some miracle.
Uh, and let's not make it out to be one because
there are lots of ways to get around paying
any corporate tax as it is.
Joe Biden would end the stepped up basis rule.
This really benefits the rich.
The way this works is if I buy $1,000 worth
of stock and I sell it for $10,000 I've profited
$9,000 you take the 10,000 you subtract out
my basis, which was the thousand bucks I paid,
so I pay taxes on the $9,000 gain.
Stepped up basis means that in certain situations,
for example, if shares are inherited when
someone dies, the recipient is able to step
up their cost basis.
So those same thousand dollars shares, if
I inherit them when they are worth $9,000
and then sell them for $10,000 I am able to
step up my basis to $9,000 and now I only
pay taxes on a gain of a thousand between
9,000 and 10,000 rather than that full gain,
Biden would get rid of that.
A Biden would put in place a 15% corporate
minimum tax.
Now this is a good idea.
The devil is in the details.
The minimum tax suggests that you've got your
official corporate tax rate of 28% you can
start to take the deduction to lower your
effective tax rate, but the minimum tax would
say that no matter what deductions you're
entitled to, you can't deduct yourself to
a point where you pay below a 15% tax rate.
That's a great idea.
The problem is often there are deductions
that are exempted from that, so it's all in
the implementation.
Still a fine idea.
21% tax on foreign profits, fine, but again,
a lot of it is how do you implement it?
Capping deductions for the wealthy is fine.
Cracking down on tax havens is a good one,
but it's vague.
There will very often be, you know, other
countries that enter with other opportunities
to avoid taxes.
It's the right idea.
Implementing it effectively is very difficult.
Biden would raise the top tax rate to 39.6%
now that's fine.
That's the top rate we had under the Obama
presidency after the Bush tax cuts expired.
Again, lots of rich people earn through capital
gains and dividends anyway.
What I would like to see are higher marginal
tax rates established for higher levels of
income.
You know, a new higher rate for a million
and above, an even higher rate for 5 million,
10 million and above.
Biden doesn't do that.
It's not surprising, but at least he's rolling
back the uh, put, putting the top tax rate
back to where it was under Barack Obama.
Biden would also close real estate loopholes
and end fossil fuel tax breaks.
That's fine.
The devil is in the details, so this is a
fine left of center tax plan.
It's way better than what we have.
It won't do anything about the military industrial
complex.
That's a budgeting thing on the spending side.
That's not a revenue thing.
It doesn't fix healthcare.
That's a separate issue.
Joe's plan is very milk toast centrist on
healthcare, but calling things what they are,
it's a tax plan that goes in the right direction
with some good tweaks.
It doesn't really shake anything up, which
is exactly what Joe Biden promised rich people.
Once again, I don't agree with much of his
policy, but Joe's being honest, he told those
rich people, nothing will fundamentally change
and challenge your privileged status in society,
which is widely unquestioned at the top echelons
of power.
He told us that that's what he would do and
that's exactly what his tax plan would do
while doing some okay things.
Let me know what you think about this tax
plan.
I know the wealth tax is missing.
I know higher tax brackets at higher income
levels are missing.
I get all of that.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Instagram at David dot.
Pacman.
Follow the show on [inaudible]
Instagram at David